welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we are
discussing supplements or more
specifically a rational guide to
supplementation now to be forthright I
want to tell you that I am not a fan of
the word supplements because it stems
from this idea that all supplements are
somehow food supplements or designed to
compensate for what one could otherwise
get from food and that's simply not the
case many supplements are compounds that
are extremely efficacious for instance
for enhancing sleep or for enhancing
hormone function or for enhancing focus
and many of those compounds are simply
not found in food or are not found in
enough abundance in food to have the
desired effect
now that raises the issue as to whether
or not these compounds are good to take
safe to take and whether or not they are
actually beneficial for us and the short
answer is that like everything else
supplements can either be good for us or
dangerous for us depending on dosage
sourcing Etc but more importantly we
need to think about supplements and a
rational guide to supplementation as
taking into account a number of
different factors and we need to set
aside the idea that all non-prescription
compounds that fall under this umbrella
term supplements are simply things that
could be extracted from food but most
people don't either ingest enough of
those Foods or pay enough attention to
their diet in order to obtain them in
fact during today's episode I'm going to
give you a number of different very
specific questions that you can answer
in order to decide whether or not you
should be taking any so-called
supplements or not and whether or not
you should be taking one type of
supplement or another type of supplement
more or less than the other I'm also
going to discuss safety of course and I
will discuss cost because obviously
monetary cost is a serious consideration
for most if not everybody considering
the use of supplements during today's
episode I will also discuss which
specific supplements are optimal for
achieving specific endpoints such as
improved sleep such as improved focus
and such as improved hormone function
among other things I plan to cover the
full range of what I referred to as
supplements including so-called
foundational supplements that are
designed to act as a sort of insurance
policy against any deficiencies that
might exist within your diet all the way
up to very targeted outcome supplements
and compounds that is compounds that are
non-prescription that are designed to
achieve very specific endpoints such as
enhanced Focus over the next four to six
hours of physical work or mental work so
on and so forth
plan to cover everything in between that
as well and I promise to cover how
supplements interact with other things
such as behavioral tools prescription
drugs when supplements might be a good
alternative to prescription drugs when
they might not be a good alternative to
prescription drugs when supplements can
serve as an augment to already excellent
nutrition and prescription protocols and
every feature of supplements as it
relates to mental health physical health
and performance by the end of today's
episode you should be armed with a
number of different questions as I
mentioned before that will allow you to
develop the most biologically effective
and cost-effective supplement regimen
for you and of course I want to
acknowledge that for some people the
total amount or dosages of a given
supplement were supplements that you
might need to take could be zero there
are such individuals but that many
people can in fact arrive tremendous
benefit from supplements in a way that
can be more cost effective than trying
to obtain the same non-prescription
nutrients from food as we head into
today's conversation I want to emphasize
something very important not just as it
relates to supplements but as it relates
to all aspects of mental health physical
health and performance and that is I
take the stance that behavioral tools
that is specific actions that we take
and specific actions that we avoid form
the foundation of mental health physical
health and performance so things like
viewing morning sunlight and exercise
are behavioral tools they don't require
the ingestion of anything within the
realm of Behavioral tools there are also
some don'ts or do not that can greatly
enhance our mental health physical
health and performance such as avoiding
bright light exposure to your eyes
between the hours of 10 pm and 4 AM or
avoiding caffeine too late in the
afternoon because even if you can fall
asleep after ingesting caffeine in the
late afternoon we know it disrupts the
architecture of your sleep in ways that
greatly diminish your mental health
physical health and performance the
following day for instance so behavioral
tools form the foundational layer of all
tools for mental health physical health
and performance second to that I would
say the next layer is in fact nutrition
no amount of supplementation or
non-prescription compounds or
prescription compounds for that matter
can never compensate for poor nutrition
at least not for very long okay so this
is a key Point even though many
supplements are not simply food
supplements because they are not
designed to compensate for anything that
you could otherwise get from food that
is not to say that you can live on
supplements you know I suppose you could
live on whey protein and fish oil
capsules and vitamin capsules or tablets
for a short while but before long you'd
either suffer from boredom to the extent
that you'd want to go back to food or
some other deficiency would show up I
think it's the rare individual that
tries to survive entirely on food
supplements and things of that sort most
everybody and I would hope everybody is
paying attention to their nutrition so I
would Place behavioral tools do's and do
Nots as layer one the deepest layer the
Bedrock of all mental health physical
health and performance
on top of that I would Place nutrition
and of course that's going to mean
different things to different people
with the understanding that there's a
huge array of different food choices and
nutritional programs
nutrition is fundamentally important for
macronutrients for storage of energy in
the form of glycogen fats and
phosphocratine stores and so forth but
also for obtaining basic nutrients
vitamins minerals and micronutrients
Okay so we've got behavioral tools
nutritional tools then on top of that I
would place what is typically called
supplementation although today I'm
trying to expand that word to include
not just things that compensate for food
deficiencies or that are layered on top
of food as a way to enhance the amount
of nutrients that you could get from
food but as I mentioned before
compounds that are non-prescription that
can be for a variety of different
purposes and many of which are not
available in food so I would place
supplementation right on top of
nutrition then past that I would say
prescription drugs obviously prescribed
from a board-certified MD can serve a
very vital purpose in the treatment or
augmentation of mental health physical
health and performance goals so some
people do in fact need prescription
antidepressants other people do not some
people do in fact need prescription
drugs for attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder or sleep Related
Disorders so on and so forth
the whole issue of whether or not there
is an over prescription epidemic or not
um is a separate conversation for a
separate podcast I would argue that many
prescription drugs do in fact save lives
this includes the category of
prescription drugs related to statins
and cardiovascular health related to any
number of different things even sleep
disorders and insomnia narcolepsy and so
forth
that said there are many instances in
which people can either reduce their
dosages of prescription compounds or can
replace those prescription compounds
with quality behavioral tools nutrition
and supplementation but there are many
instances in which prescription drugs
are the only route by which people can
achieve the mental health physical
health and performance goals that they
wish to achieve so I would place that as
the fourth layer in this stack of layers
directed towards mental health physical
health and performance so just to list
off again I fundamentally believe that
behaviors do's and do Nots form the
foundation of mental health physical
health performance and next in line
would be nutrition
that is the specific Foods we eat the
amount that we eat the combinations of
foods that we eat in a given sitting and
the timing in which we eat our food then
on top of that I would Place
supplementation the topic of today's
episode and finally prescription drugs
and of course all of these things
interact in important and interesting
ways many of which interactions we will
discuss during today's podcast as we
drill into the topic of supplementation
developing a rational supplementation
protocol and one that is most
biologically and cost effective before
moving further into today's episode I
want to emphasize a very important point
which is that I am not a physician that
is I'm not a clinician so I do not
prescribe anything nor am I going to do
that today I'm a professor I review the
research literature I describe tools
gleaned from the research literature and
developed from the research literature
so I profess many things but I do not
prescribe anything and I think it's
vitally important that anytime you are
thinking of adding or subtracting any
behavioral protocols nutritional
protocols supplementation based
protocols and certainly prescription
drug based protocols
for whatever purpose that you consult a
trusted board-certified physician that's
absolutely essential I don't say that
merely to protect me I mainly say that
to protect you the most important aspect
of today's episode is not going to be
that you discover one particular
supplement or category of supplements or
blend of supplements that is going to
transform your mental health physical
health and performance
no the purpose of today's episode is for
you to understand where you have needs
that can be met by supplementation
better than any other approach and most
importantly how to think about
supplementation that is how to think
about the different categories of
supplements that are out there and how
those interact with your nutrition and
your behaviors so that you can maximize
your immediate and long-term health
what I mean by this is that we have this
word supplements or supplementation but
that means many many different things it
means vitamins it means minerals it
means adaptogens most people probably
don't even know what an adaptogen really
is and in fact many people talking about
adaptogens never actually Define what an
adaptogen is or designed for or the fact
that many adaptogens are also used for
other purposes so today's discussion is
really about you learning how to think
about supplementation the same way you
would learn to think about nutrition or
exercise or anything related to brain
and body health for that matter in a way
that lets you navigate this vast space
that we call supplementation and develop
protocols that are optimal for you and
indeed it may be the case that the ideal
dosage of a given supplement for you is
zero milligrams for instance if I ask
you are you sleeping deeply and enough
each night do you feel rested throughout
the day maybe you need a short nap and
that's it or maybe you don't and you say
yes I feel great I sleep great I wake up
feeling great I only need a short nap or
no nap during the day to feel rested
throughout the day well then there's
really no discussion about sleep
supplementation to be had between you
and me however
if you are not sleeping well then a big
discussion opens up as to what the
reasons are as it relate to nutrition or
when you're exercising or ingesting
caffeine in other words no discussion
about supplementation can be had in a
vacuum
rather discussions about supplementation
need to be considered in a larger
context so today you're going to learn
how to place the discussion and thinking
about supplementation in a larger
context and think about how specific
supplements that is specific ingredients
and combinations of ingredients can
indeed be used to buffer and support
your overall health and lead you to
specific health and performance outcomes
before we begin I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is momentous momentous
makes supplements of the absolute
highest quality the huberman Lab podcast
has decided to partner with momentous
because of the extremely high quality of
momentous supplements and because they
have single ingredient formulations as
we'll discuss more on today's episode
single ingredient formulations are
essential for most all aspects effects
of developing a rational highly
efficacious supplement regimen and
that's because the ideal supplement
regimen allows you to adjust the dosages
of individual ingredients as well as
alternate days in which specific
ingredients are consumed it also allows
you for instance to assess whether or
not one given ingredient works for you
and another ingredient does not and it
also allows you to assess whether or not
any side effects originate from a
specific component of your supplement
protocol another advantage of momentous
supplements is that they ship anywhere
in the world because we realize that
many of you reside outside of the United
States if you'd like to try any of the
supplements mentioned in today's or
other episodes of The huberman Lab
podcast so for instance things related
to sleep augmentation hormone
augmentation enhancing Focus metabolic
health or otherwise you can go to live
momentous spelled ous so
livemomentis.com huberman and you'll get
20 off any of their products today's
episode is also brought To Us by element
element is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't that means plenty of sodium
magnesium and potassium the so-called
electrolytes and no sugar getting
sufficient hydration and electrolytes is
key to brain health and body health and
that's because every cell in your brain
and body relies on having enough
electrolytes available in order to
function this is especially true of the
so-called neurons or nerve cells in your
brain they actually require sufficient
amounts of sodium and potassium and
magnesium but especially sodium and
potassium available to them in order to
fire what are called Action potentials
or electrical signals that's what allows
you to think to feel to move what gives
you energy so on and so forth so when
you are dehydrated oftentimes you will
need to get electrolytes and that's true
if you're exercising a lot or if you
sweat a lot but for many people it's
just true because they're not consuming
enough water and electrolytes in the
form of liquids and Foods throughout the
day element contains a science back
electrolyte ratio of 1 000 milligrams of
sodium 200 milligrams of potassium and
60 milligrams of magnesium if you'd like
to try element you can go to drink
element that's lmnt.com huberman to
claim a free element and sample pack
with your purchase again that's drink
element lmnt.com huberman to get a free
sample pack today's episode is brought
To Us by Helix sleep Helix sleep makes
mattresses and pillows that are
absolutely phenomenal I've been sleeping
on a helix mattress for close to two
years now and it's the best sleep that
I've ever had one of the reasons is the
mattress is customized to you so you
simply go to the Helix site you take a
brief two minute quiz it asks you
questions like you tend to sleep on your
back your side of your stomach or maybe
all of those across the night or maybe
you don't know you tend to run hot
during the night or cold during the
night or maybe you don't know and they
match you to the ideal mattress for you
for me it was the dusk dusk mattress
that allowed me to achieve the best
sleep of my life if you're interested in
upgrading your mattress you can go to
helixsleep.com huberman take their brief
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress for your
sleep needs and you'll get up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
they have a 10 year warranty on their
mattresses and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free three they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love the
mattress although I think you absolutely
will again if you're interested you can
go to Helix sleep.com huberman to get up
to 200 off and two free pillows let's
talk about supplements and
supplementation and how to develop a
rational supplementation regimen one of
the things that's really emerged over
the last 20 years is that supplements
and there I'm referring to
non-prescription compounds designed to
augment nutrition prescription drugs and
behavioral protocols
have emerged as a Mainstay within the
health and wellness but also the medical
communities that are focused on
developing mental health physical health
and performance for their patients and
their athletes and for the everyday
person essentially what I'm saying is
that 20 years ago a discussion about
supplements would mainly take place
within the niche communities of health
food stores or particular athletes but
nowadays I think almost everyone is
familiar with the fact that yes indeed
there are standard vitamin supplements
but that there are also supplements such
as Vitamin D3 which are designed to make
sure that people have certain amounts of
hormones in their bloodstream because
they might not be getting enough
Sunshine although I'll be very clear
over and over throughout this episode
that there is no pill replacement for
Sunshine nor is there a pill replacement
or food replacement for that matter for
exercise or for social connection or for
sleep or for simply getting smarter
again there is no pill that's going to
replace excellent behavioral protocols
in fact a physician friend of mine has a
great saying that I think everybody
should keep in mind
as we wade into this conversation which
is that Better Living Through Chemistry
still requires Better Living
I think that's a very important phrase
to keep in mind when thinking about the
optimal supplementation or prescription
drug protocol for you so what is an
ideal supplementation protocol well I
think what we need to do is to take a
step back and ask what are different
supplements designed to do for instance
there are foundational supplements these
are supplements that are designed to
establish a foundation or provide
Insurance along with your nutritional
intake to ensure that you're getting all
the things that you need in order to
have a basic level of mental health
physical health and opportunity for
Optimal Performance now this is the one
category of supplements for which I
think it's appropriate and in fact
advantageous to have multiple
ingredients in a given supplement
throughout the rest of today's
discussion I'm going to talk about the
advantage of mainly focusing on taking
single ingredient formulations for a
variety of reasons but when it comes to
foundational supplements
what we're mainly talking about are
supplements that contain vitamins and
minerals that are designed to compensate
for any deficiencies you might have from
diet or from lack of adequate diet how
would such a lack of vitamin and mineral
intake arise well for instance if you're
somebody that practices intermittent
fasting or other components of fasting
or if you're somebody who does not get
enough vitamins and minerals from
vegetables and fruits and Grains and
meats well then taking a supplement that
can
act as a insurance policy against any
vitamin mineral deficiencies in many
ways can be advantageous although I will
talk about some of the safety concerns
in just a few minutes now I want to
acknowledge that as soon as we talk
about vitamin mineral supplements the
Skeptics immediately raise their hands
and say well all that vitamin and
mineral supplements do is give you very
expensive urine and there the Skeptics
are referring to the fact the reality
that when you ingest high levels of
water-soluble vitamins so think vitamin
C and some of the other vitamins that
indeed you will excrete them in your
urine
however
it's also the case that many people are
not getting enough of the water-soluble
vitamins from their foods and it's also
the case that many people are and it's
also the case that ingesting higher than
needed amounts of most water-soluble
vitamins provided those levels aren't
exceedingly High
is or at least we should say can be safe
and again this is provided that the
levels that they're ingesting are not
exceedingly high so the typical vitamin
mineral supplement is indeed going to
cover any gaps or deficiencies that
might arise in the water-soluble
vitamins from your food intake but the
reality is that most people are getting
enough of the water-soluble vitamins
from their food if they are paying
attention to a couple of things
and those things are very simple to lay
out regardless of whether or not you're
a vegan a vegetarian a more traditional
omnivore eating from both animal-based
and plant-based sources grains Etc or
even if you're in the pure carnivore or
strict I guess it's called The Lion diet
where it's just meat and salt regardless
of what type of nutrition you follow you
will get vitamins and minerals but
you'll get more or fewer of them
depending on the nutritional program you
follow and of course depending on how
often and how much you eat that's just
sort of obvious
most people who take a vitamin mineral
supplement
will indeed excrete a lot of the
water-soluble vitamins they will retain
the fat soluble vitamins and there again
the Skeptics will raise their hands and
say you do not want to take high levels
of fat soluble vitamins because they
will be stored in your system
potentially to levels that are dangerous
again provided that vitamin mineral
supplements are not taken in excess it's
unlikely that you're going to have such
a buildup of the fat soluble vitamins in
your system that they're going to be a
problem so that raises a very specific
question that you need to ask do you
want to take a vitamin mineral
supplement well the answer to that will
be highly individual but you really just
need to address two things first of all
is the cost within the range that you
can afford and want to pay right
oftentimes these vitamin mineral
supplements can be quite inexpensive but
some of them can be quite expensive and
you can see the full range of ones that
are pennies per day all the way up to
many dollars or tens of dollars per day
because of what are reported to be
variations in quality and sourcing and
so forth I'm not aware of any real
differences between the quality of the
water soluble and fat soluble vitamins
found in the less expensive versus the
more expensive vitamin mineral
supplements more typically the cost
scales with the dosages of these
different vitamins and minerals and as
could probably be expected the more
expensive to obtain and source
vitamins and minerals tend to be in
lower quantities in the less expensive
versions of vitamin mineral supplements
that's just kind of obvious so you need
to ask yourself can you afford it
financially and then you need to ask
yourself are you able to regularly
ingest enough foods with enough variety
to cover your vitamin mineral
needs just from food and for some people
the answer is going to be an immediate
yes they are careful to get enough of
the foods that allow them to obtain
their vitamin and mineral quota and for
other individuals the answer will be no
I would say for people that are
extremely physically and or mentally
active and for people that perhaps are
following a intermittent fasting
schedule so they are not ingesting a lot
of food in general or restricting their
food intake to specific times of day
well then a vitamin mineral supplement
likely makes sense for them however it's
going to be very important to ingest
that vitamin mineral supplement with
food and ideally early in the day so
that can set up a little bit of a
challenge for the intermittent fasters
who are restricting their feeding window
to late in the day why do I say this
well many of the water-soluble vitamins
in particular the B vitamins need to be
ingested with food because otherwise
they can cause some stomach upset and
again there's a range there some people
like myself can take B vitamins on an
empty stomach and feel fine other people
feel really lousy when they take B
vitamins there are a few other things
that we'll talk about later namely zinc
and coenzyme Q10 that really should also
be taken with food but the best time to
take a vitamin mineral supplement is
with food and I believe that if you're
going to take a vitamin mineral
supplement
that you want to take it with food and
you don't want to take dosages of
vitamins and minerals from supplements
that are exceedingly high for a couple
of reasons one is the buildup of fat
soluble vitamins that we talked about
before the other reason is that when
people tend to take very high levels of
vitamins and minerals from supplements
they tend to spend less time and focus
on making sure that they're optimizing
their nutrition or at least trying to
get their nutrition right what do I mean
by getting their nutrition right well I
think regardless of whether or not your
keto omnivore carnivore
vegan or any other nutritional plan
the key thing is to get most that is
about 75 to 80 of your Foods or more
from non-processed or minimally
processed sources I think there is
agreement across the board that most
people should avoid highly processed
foods highly processed foods are going
to be foods with very long ingredient
lists that have very long shelf lives so
this often includes snack foods it does
include snack foods like chips Etc
pastries that could sit on the Shelf a
long time
but it also includes things like canned
soups and number of different other
foods that have many many ingredients
preservatives most people would do well
to avoid those kinds of foods and focus
most of their intake on things that are
non-processed so these would be things
like fruits and vegetables you'll notice
that the non-processed foods will tend
to have very short shelf life or require
refrigeration in some cases such as meat
eggs Etc
or minimally processed foods such as you
know rice and oatmeals and pastas beans
and things of that sort beans oftentimes
can be completely unprocessed as well of
course these are two general categories
unprocessed and minimally process that
should make up about 80 or more of your
food intake if your goal is health and
obtaining adequate amounts of vitamins
and minerals the so-called foundational
supplements include of course vitamin
and mineral supplements
but has expanded over the last decade or
more to also include supplements that
have vitamins and minerals but also
things like digestive enzymes and again
here we have an example where indeed you
can get digestive enzymes from foods for
instance eating a bit of papaya or even
a little bit of Pineapple can
assist in the digestion of certain
aspects of macronutrients because these
are naturally occurring enzymes that
help digest things like carbohydrates
fats and proteins
and there are other food-based sources
of enzymes you're welcome to look those
up online if you just put food based
sources of enzymes and you'll find those
but nowadays A lot of the foundational
supplements will include
papain or they will include different
lipases or anytime you hear the word Ace
by the way it means an enzyme an enzyme
is designed to break down or to catalyze
some sort of reaction in biology and
nutrition in particular so you can find
foundational supplements that include
vitamins and minerals and digestive
enzymes and nowadays more and more the
quality foundational supplements are
also including things like adaptogens
and here the name adaptogens is sort of
vague and it indeed has no specific
operational definition this is something
really important to understand about
supplementation is that companies and
indeed podcasts can talk about
adaptogens without actually defining
what an adaptogen is
in an operational way when we say
operational what we mean is a definition
that everyone in a given Arena or space
research for instance can agree on so
that when we talk about the adaptogenic
effects of a given compound we're all
talking about the same things well
foundational supplements nowadays
include vitamins minerals digestive
enzymes and the so-called adaptogens and
the adaptogens broadly speaking are
thought to improve the body and brain's
ability ability to buffer against
various stressors so these could be
things like herbs like ashwagandha that
are designed to reduce cortisol levels
in that sense ashwagandha is an
adaptogen but ashwagandha has other
effects related to hormone augmentation
in both the testosterone and estrogen
and maybe even the thyroid Pathways
we'll talk about this a little bit later
when we talk about supplements for
hormone augmentation so foundational
supplements has really expanded to
include a lot of different categories of
nutrients and micronutrients vitamins
and minerals digestive enzymes designed
to achieve a broad spectrum of effects
again this is the one category of
supplementation where I think it makes
sense to explore
multi-ingredient formulations and the
other thing that's often included in
these so-called foundational supplements
are probiotics or prebiotics
which are designed to augment and
support the so-called gut microbiome the
gut microbiome is the collection of
trillions of little micro bacteria that
exist in all of us they mainly exist in
the mucous membrane-lined tissues of the
body so that would be your nasal
passages your mouth
the vagina the urethra and the gut the
whole way from your mouth all the way
out the other end so not just your
stomach trillions of bacteria live there
trillions of microbacteria also live on
your skin in fact every time you shake
someone's hand you're exchanging
microbacteria
these micro bacteria often are healthy
for us good for us they support a huge
number of positive biological functions
but there are other microbacteria that
live in our gut and Elsewhere on those
mucous line tissues that can be
disadvantageous for us that can harm our
health a growing idea these days based
on a number of different Laboratories
work including the laboratory of my
upstairs neighbor at Stanford Dr Justin
Sonnenberg who's been a guest on this
podcast is that having a great diversity
a range of microbiota as they're called
microbiome microbiota and these
microbacteria are all essentially
referring to the same thing the
microbiome is the whole collection of
these microbacteria but having a lot of
different so-called species of these
microbacteria is known to be
advantageous for immune system function
hormone function it supports the
so-called gut brain axis that's
important for a number of things
including mood and motivation actually
supports the production of
neurotransmitters in the brain and body
that can help keep you motivated
elevated mood
support the general function of neurons
well not surprisingly there are ways to
support the gut microbiome and there are
ways to harm the gut microbiome I'll
refer to to the podcast episode we did
with Justin Sonnenberg you can find that
at hubermanlab.com if you want to learn
all the different ways you can support
your gut microbiome but for sake of
today's discussion I want to emphasize
that some of those methods of supporting
the gut microbiome are through the
direct consumption of particular foods
and there are two categories of foods
that if you're getting enough of them
it's likely that your gut microbiome is
diverse and is going to support all
those important functions I just listed
off and other functions as well the two
sources of gut microbiota supporting
foods are low sugar fermented foods so
these would be things like sauerkraut
kimchi
Greek yogurt again low sugar Greek
yogurt
um
kombucha in particular as a drink things
like kefir there are a bunch of other
varieties of fermented foods different
cultures have different fermented foods
so Japanese natto is um another source
of of ferment that is very good for the
gut microbiome and work from Justin
sonnenberg's lab and close by Labs at
Stanford School of Medicine have shown
that
if people ingest
four servings a day of these low sugar
fermented foods it greatly improves the
function of the gut microbiome and in
particular enhances the function of the
immune system and it reduces the
so-called inflammatorium it reduces
inflammation in the brain and body in
the ways that are helpful and effective
for brain and body that is mental health
physical health and performance so there
are ways to support your gut microbiome
strictly from food but it should come as
no surprise that most people are not
ingesting four servings a day of
fermented foods hopefully they're
getting enough fiber
especially Prebiotic fiber which is one
other way to support the gut microbiome
although the studies from Justin
sonnenberg's lab point to the fact that
fiber intake itself was not directly
supportive of the gut microbiome in
everybody it was in some individuals but
not in others and some had no effect and
in other individuals it actually made
the
category or I should say the array of
inflammatory markers worse it actually
led to more inflammation so that's not
to say that fiber is bad in fact in the
episode that we did with Dr Lane Norton
he discussed the many benefits of
getting enough fiber there are a lot of
reasons why people should get enough
fiber in their diet but at least for
supporting the gut microbiome
four servings a day of low sugar
fermented foods
seems to be the best way to support the
gut microbiome through the intake of
nutrition again most people are not
achieving that and therefore these
foundational supplements that can be
just vitamin and mineral supplements or
it could be vitamin and mineral
supplements plus digestive enzymes or
both of those things plus adaptogens now
also tend to include prebiotics and
probiotics that are designed to support
the proliferation and maintenance of
enough gut microbiota in order to
support the gut microbiome and the gut
brain axis now because of the importance
of the gut microbiome and because most
people are not getting enough support
for the gut microbiome in the form of
low sugar fermented foods and Prebiotic
fiber from their diet
I think perhaps one of the most
essential foundational supplements
irrespective of whether or not it
includes vitamins and minerals
adaptogens and digestive enzymes is some
way to support the gut microbiome now
this gets into a whole dimension of
of categories of Prebiotic and probiotic
capsules and one needs to be very
careful there I do want to say that most
of the Prebiotic and probiotic capsules
that you can buy first of all are very
expensive the best ones are going to be
refrigerated or required Refrigeration
just as do any good low sugar fermented
foods by the way so for instance pickles
are a low sugar fermented food that can
support the gut microbiome but if you're
buying pickles from the section of the
grocery store where they the pickles are
not
refrigerated well then you're not going
to get the gut microbiome supporting
effects from those pickles it's so funny
we're even having this conversation
talking about pickles but the reality is
they can greatly enhance the microbiota
if you are getting the pickles that are
and require refrigeration and include
the brine which is the the liquid around
them the same is true for sauerkraut
non-refrigerated sauerkraut is not going
to support your gut microbiome it will
supply some other things perhaps but
it's not going to support your gut
microbiome it has to be the refrigerated
versions for the reason that most people
are not getting enough food based
support for the gut microbiome and
because of the importance of the gut
microbiome one of the key categories of
foundational supplements are supplements
that create
support for the microbiome through
prebiotics or probiotics again they tend
to be the refrigerated varieties are the
ones that are actually going to work
those also tend to be very expensive
and there are some evidence that taking
excessive amounts of prebiotics and
probiotics that is typical of these
capsule forms of prebiotics and
probiotics if they're taken ongoing not
for short periods of time but if they're
taken ongoing can lead to some issues
like brain fog there's a nice literature
on this that and a growing one at that
so my suggestion is that if people are
going to take supplements to support the
microbiome that those supplements
include low enough levels that is small
enough amounts of prebiotics and
probiotics that you don't start to
venture into the realm of brain fog and
some of the other issues that could be
associated with taking too much
Prebiotic and probiotic in the form of
supplements I'd like to take a brief
break and thank our sponsor inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test the
problem with a lot of blood and DNA
tests out there however is that you get
data back about metabolic factors lipids
and hormones and so forth but you don't
know what to do with those data inside
tracker solves that problem and makes it
very easy for you to understand what
sorts of nutritional behavioral maybe
even supplementation based interventions
you might want to take on in order to
adjust the numbers of those metabolic
factors hormones lipids and other things
that impact your immediate and long-term
Health to bring those numbers into the
ranges that are appropriate and indeed
optimal for you if you'd like to try
inside tracker you can visit inside
tracker.com huberman and get 20 off any
of inside tracker's plans that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off the
other category foundational supplements
are those adaptogens that we mentioned
earlier adaptogens again being a very
poorly defined category but these are
typically
micronutrients herbs sometimes they go
into the mushroom category again these
are non psychedelic mushrooms that
provide either some buffering to the
stress system by reducing cortisol
typically or that are thought to or
known to based on research studies to
enhance things like blood flow to the
brain or to enhance some aspect of
cognitive function by way of enhancing
neurotransmitter function
this category of so-called adaptogens is
an important one we'll get back to this
a little bit later the reason I mention
it now is that it is indeed hard to get
the so-called adaptogens in sufficient
concentrations from food-based sources I
have to assume that most people aren't
out there collecting chaga mushroom or
the ashwagandha herbs and then combining
them with their salads or their foods
and so that's why this adaptogen
category fits into foundational now this
opens up the category of foundational
supplements that are broad spectrum that
is that include vitamins and minerals
that have digestive enzymes that have
adaptogens and that also have prebiotics
and probiotics at the appropriate
dosages this is one reason why I'm a big
fan of supplements like athletic greens
which is as many of you know a sponsor
of this podcast and does really nicely
cover all of these categories of
foundational nutrition but I do want to
emphasize that this is not a way to
focus on athletic greens specifically
there are other categories and brands of
excellent foundational nutritional
supplements that cover these categories
of vitamins and minerals probiotics
prebiotics digestive enzymes and
adaptogens it just so happens that that
athletic greens is the one that I
discovered and that works best for me
and that many people find works really
well for them so this is why when people
approach me and they ask me as they
often do very very often do I should say
if I'm only going to take one supplement
what supplement should I take rather
than just give them one specific answer
I actually asked them three questions
first question I ask them is how well
are you sleeping at night are you
getting enough sleep are you waking up
feeling rested because if they're not
that opens up a whole different set of
interactions that we need to have and
discussions around what sorts of things
they need to do and possibly take in
order to get their sleep right because
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance we will
have that discussion a little bit later
in this episode
the second question I asked them is
how's your nutrition that is are you
eating regularly have you found the
combination of macronutrients or which
diet is right for you do you think
you're getting enough vitamins and
minerals how's your digestion we have
that conversation and then the third
thing that I ask which is extremely
important is what's your budget because
if somebody has ten dollars a month
total to spend on supplements versus a
thousand dollars a month to spend on
supplements total well then there's a
different set of conversations to be had
as to which supplements they should take
now once those three questions have been
answered
assuming that somebody is able to spend
about a hundred dollars or more on
supplements per month
then my recommendation is that they not
focus on any specific supplements
directed towards sleep or toward Focus
or hormone augmentation but rather that
they focus on buffering and enhancing
their foundational nutrition adaptogens
probiotics prebiotics and digestive
enzymes because of the simple fact that
if they do that they're going to raise
the tide on all the biological and organ
systems that are going to lead to
enhanced mental health physical health
and performance including sleep
so this is one reason why if people say
well if I can only take one supplement
what should I take I say well what's
your budget if they say they can meet
that hundred dollar threshold per month
then my recommendation would be athletic
greens or something like it or that they
invest the time and energy to go find
the various combinations of vitamins and
minerals and probiotics and prebiotics
and adaptogens and so forth in
individual
components that they can then take in
combination in order to meet their
foundational needs but most people are
not interested in doing all that
homework and legwork to figure out
exactly what those dosages are that's
one reason why indeed I have taken
athletic green since 2012. I like it it
makes me feel better I have more energy
I sleep better my digestion is certainly
better and it supports the gut
microbiome I do that for that reason but
again I want to emphasize that there are
other great sources of all the relevant
things within those foundational
formulas that athletic greens contains
so it's certainly not the only route to
covering your foundational Health needs
there are other ways to do that now if
somebody has a budget lower than a
hundred dollars per month to spend on
foundational supplementation well then
there are a couple of discussions to be
had now if the amount of money that they
have to devote to foundational
supplementation is zero of course
respect that and then it becomes a
discussion about what sorts of foods and
patterns of food intake are going to
best support their mental health
physical health performance now if
somebody has somewhere between zero
dollars and fifty dollars to spend on
supplementation for sake of this thing
we're calling foundational Health per
month well then a different category of
supplement discussion arises and we'll
have that in a moment but to sort of
close the conversation on foundational
supplementation
again that means many different things
it's vitamins and minerals sometimes
that's one vitamin and mineral
supplement it means digestive enzymes
that could be its own supplement or in
combination with vitamins and minerals
it means often not always adaptogens
things like ashwagandha different
plant-based and mushroom-based
formulations that can buffer stress and
provide other brain and body support
and it often although not always but
should I believe include the probiotics
and prebiotics or anything that supports
healthy gut microbiome
once again I think a broad spectrum
supplement that has many many
ingredients of high quality that covers
all these bases is going to be the best
route to ensuring foundational
supplementation is covered and I do
think that should be the starting place
for any and all supplementation regimens
I'll say that once again I think
covering your foundational needs in the
realm of vitamins minerals probiotics
digestive enzymes and
adaptogens is going to give you the most
benefit
by cost and the most benefit across the
board in terms of brain and body systems
that's going to allow you to feel better
overall sleep better overall focus
better overall and support all the
different systems in your brain and body
that are going to allow you to be at
your best while of course also paying
careful attention to your nutrition
because you simply cannot abandon
nutrition again Better Living Through
Chemistry still requires Better Living
so now that we've had that discussion
about foundational supplementation
and again highlighting the fact that
that's the one category of
supplementation where multi-ingredient
formulations make the most sense I'd
like to now shift our attention to
single ingredient formulation
supplements that are designed to achieve
specific endpoints and here again rather
than focus on specific ingredients and
supplements to achieve specific
endpoints because we've done that
already in episodes related to sleep and
focus Etc
I'd like to take a step back and focus
on the larger theme of today's episode
which is how to think about
supplementation in a rational cost
effective and biologically effective way
for each of these categories and the
three categories that I'm going to cover
are sleep
hormone support and cognitive
enhancement and focus cognitive
enhancement and focus being the final
third category
let's talk about sleep and the rational
approach to thinking about
supplementation for sleep as I mentioned
earlier in this episode and on many
previous episodes of this podcast sleep
is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance
you might be somebody who can do an
all-nighter and feel okay the next day
or maybe even great but most everybody
once they start to have minimal sleep
for one or two nights in the form of
broken sleep poor sleep not enough sleep
or sleeping at the wrong time of night
there is such a thing or day
they start to suffer their mood starts
to suffer their cognitive Clarity and
performance starts to suffer their
mental health can suffer severely and
physical performance definitely suffers
hormone suffer everything suffers
conversely
when people are sleeping well that is
deeply and enough eighty percent of the
nights of their life
mental health physical health and
performance all flourish and I think
most people start to be almost amazed at
how well they're doing in various
domains of life that previously they
might have struggled with so sleep is
fundamental that's that's established
when thinking about supplementation for
sleep we need to ask ourselves a number
of important questions first of all you
should ask yourself how well that is how
deeply and how much are you sleeping per
night assuming you're somebody who can
fall asleep easily stay asleep through
the night wake up feeling relatively
rested maybe a little groggy and then
can move about your day with plenty of
energy and focus you're not falling
asleep in class or at work or behind the
wheel whereas a passenger on public
transportation
well then you're probably getting enough
sleep and by the way it's perfectly
normal to require anywhere from a 10
minute to a 90 minute nap in the
afternoon for some people if you're not
a napper no big deal it's known that
naps can disrupt nighttime sleep but
provided that they're early enough in
the day if you take a nap and you are
still able to fall asleep at night then
naps are fine for you if you're somebody
who doesn't like naps because you wake
up groggy or grumpy which often happens
to certain people then don't nap
you certainly do not need to nap but if
you're feeling energetic throughout the
day chances are you're getting enough
sleep at night but there are people of
course who are struggling with sleep
either falling asleep staying asleep or
they're not feeling alert enough during
the day or all of the above and then it
makes sense to step back and take a look
at what supplementation can provide
if you are one of those people who is
not sleeping enough or well enough at
night that you are suffering during the
day in whatever way mild to severe there
are two questions you should ask
yourself first of all are you ingesting
caffeine after 2 pm if the answer is yes
you want to limit or eliminate caffeine
after 2 pm maybe even push it back to
noon or earlier I know that can be
excruciating for some folks but it can
really help with your ability to fall
and stay asleep at night second thing is
most people would do well to avoid food
within the two hours prior to bedtime
but of course you don't want to be so
hungry that you can't fall asleep all
right so those are the nutrition and
behavioral tools that everyone needs to
consider if you are not ingesting
caffeine
2 p.m or onwards and you are not eating
excessively immediately prior to bedtime
or within the two hours prior to bedtime
and you're not hungry when you go to
sleep well then there are certain
supplements that can support your sleep
and we've talked about these in the
perfect sleep episode and in the episode
with our guest expert Matt Walker from
University of California Berkeley and in
the master your sleep episode and we
have a tool kit for sleep that you can
access zero cost by going to
hearinglab.com and going to the menu go
to the newsletter and you can find that
toolkit you can sign up for other free
toolkits like it but
the point here is not to go
systematically through each of the
supplements that is beneficial or has
been shown to be beneficial for sleep
but rather to address specific aspects
of sleep that can suffer and why and how
certain patterns of supplementation can
support or alleviate those pain points
if for instance you're somebody who
falls asleep just fine but wakes up in
the middle of the night
around 2 or 3 A.M or any time for that
matter and has trouble falling back
asleep there are two categories of
supplements that you might want to
consider the first is myoinositol
typically taken as 900 milligrams of
myoinositol myoinositol can help shorten
the amount of time that it takes to fall
back asleep if you wake up in the middle
of the night myoinositol has other
beneficial uses as well for mood Etc if
you'd like to see many of the different
effects that have been explored in the
scientific literature from myoinositol
you can go to examine.com it's an
excellent site not just for inositol but
for all supplements for that matter
talks about the human effect Matrix that
is the different effects of different
supplement compounds on different
aspects of hormone brain and body Health
where the evidence is strong where the
evidence is weak has links to studies
and so on again it's examine.com amazing
website wonderful website it's provided
such a rich resource for me and for you
know many many other people
other people who wake up in the middle
of the night will wake up because their
dreams are very intense or they were
having dreams that were so vivid that
suddenly they were jolted from their
dreams those people would do well to
avoid certain supplements so in a moment
I'll talk about the value of a
supplement called theanine for falling
asleep but theanine which typically is
taken in dosages anywhere from 100
milligrams to 400 milligrams depending
on body weight and experience and what
you find to be most effective for you
minimally effective for you well the
Indian can be great for many people but
for people who have excessively vivid
dreams
those excessively vivid dreams can lead
to immediate waking and sometimes a
little bit of anxiety upon waking in the
middle of the night so some people who
wake up in the middle of the night so
jolted
mentally and physically out of sleep
because of their intense dreams would do
well to avoid theanine supplementation
I've talked about this a bit before but
it's something that I think a lot of
nighttime middle of the night wakers
might be familiar with and would want to
take into consideration now for those of
you that are not waking up in the middle
of the night or not having excessively
vivid dreams but are having trouble
falling asleep
two supplements in particular have been
shown to be effective for shortening the
transition time to sleep and allowing
people to ease into sleep more readily
and those are magnesium 3 and 8 which is
interchangeable with magnesium bis
glycinate
magnesium bisclycinate and magnesium
threonate both
have transporter systems that allow them
to readily cross the blood-brain barrier
and they lead to a mild form of
drowsiness mild in the sense that it's
not going to prevent you from operating
a motor vehicle or kind of any
conditions under emergency that might
arise in the middle of the night or if
they did a rise during the middle of
night you'd still be able to function so
it's not like a sleeping pill but people
who take those often find that their
transition time into sleep is much
faster and their sleep is also much
deeper incidentally those supplements
are also thought to be useful for
cognitive support and neuroprotection
although there's less data on that
okay so that's for falling asleep that's
one category either magnesium magnesium
three and eight or bis glycine would be
interchangeable for assisting the
transition time into sleep and then the
other supplement is apogenin API
g-e-n-i-n apogenin which is a derivative
of chamomile I've talked about this in
various podcasts before also acts as a
bit of a anxiety lowering compound which
is essential prior to sleep for people
to essentially turn off their thinking
or to be able to reduce the amount of
ruminating and problem solving and
future anticipation that they're doing
which is a requirement for falling
asleep so what's the rational approach
to supplementing in a way that allows
you to fall asleep more quickly and stay
asleep well would you immediately take
magnesium three Nate and apogenin
together well that depends if you have
the budget and you just simply want to
fall asleep quicker and you don't care
which of those two ingredients is going
to be more effective for you well then
you could try one for instance magnesium
three and eight and try it for perhaps a
week and see how that affects your
latency to sleep time that is how
quickly you fall asleep or you can try
apogenic in the first week or you could
combine them both or you could try
magnesium three night for a week then
switch to only apogenin for a week and
evaluate which one works better for you
if neither works for you I do recommend
trying the combination together again
this is just the way that any scientist
would design an experiment to try and
understand which variables that is which
ingredients are most effective for the
result that you want as opposed to just
lumping them together and taking them
that said a lot of people want excellent
sleep so badly that they just say okay
I'm just going to take magnesium 3 and 8
I'm going to take apogen and I'm going
to take theanine if my dreams are too
Vivid and I'm waking up in the middle of
the night from excessively vivid dreams
I'll drop the theanine and many people
actually derive great benefit from that
approach but because today we're talking
about the most rational cost effective
and biologically effective approach to
supplementation if you're not sleeping
as well as you would like to
or if you want to explore what sleeping
even more deeply might do for your
mental health physical health and
performance well then it makes sense to
think about the various supplements for
falling asleep versus remaining asleep
what to include what not to include and
to do that systematically and again I
think one week's time of taking
something provided it doesn't
induce any negative effects right if
something induces a negative effect I
recommend ceasing taking it immediately
but if something does not produce any
negative effects then I think you want
to try a single ingredient formulation
for about a week while not varying
anything else not changing anything else
in your overall Protocols of nutrition
or supplementation I mean it's
impossible to clamp everything perfectly
from week to week but you know don't
change anything else dramatically and
just add that supplement for a given
week see how it benefits your sleep
maybe add in a second second supplement
if you like or rather Swap and try a
different supplement for a week and then
see what works best and see if the
combination works even better now I
acknowledge that what I just described
is exceedingly basic but it's something
that I don't think most people do most
people either decide they have the
budget and the interest in just
improving their sleep across the board
and they don't care what ingredient is
providing the maximum benefit or they
simply try something and decide oh well
it didn't work for me and so I'm not
going to try anything else supplements
don't work for me or magnesium doesn't
work for me or
um you know I woke up in the middle of
the night from vivid dreams and that's
because they're taking more of a shotgun
approach without teasing out the
different variables in fact if there's
an overriding theme of today's
conversation it's really about learning
how to isolate variables in the realm of
supplementation because once you do that
and once you start to develop that
Intuition or sensitivity of sorts to how
different ingredients impact you
it is an enormously powerful stance to
have because you're going to keep your
costs limited you're also going to find
the things that work particularly poorly
for you and more importantly the things
that work particularly well for you
toward your goals any discussion about
supplementation for sleep
I feel has to include a discussion about
melatonin I've talked about melatonin
before on numerous podcasts mine and
others and I will say once again I am
not a fan of melatonin for a couple of
reasons melatonin is a hormone known to
induce sleepiness but not keep us asleep
so oftentimes people will take melatonin
fall deeply asleep and then wake up and
have trouble falling back asleep the
other reason is that melatonin
supplements almost always include levels
of melatonin or amounts of melatonin
that far far exceed the normal
biological levels or so-called
endogenous levels of melatonin that we
would normally produce and yes it's true
that as we age we produce less melatonin
but melatonin as a hormone also impacts
other hormone systems in particular the
reproductive hormone access testosterone
estrogen Etc which is not to say that if
you've been taking melatonin for some
period of time that you've disrupted
your fertility or those hormone axes but
it's possible that you've disrupted them
somewhat and it's very clear that
melatonin can impact not just sleep but
other systems in the brain and body it
can be useful for jet lag and for
occasional use but they're also I want
to voice a message of caution
there have been studies exploring the
dosages of melatonin contained in
various supplements
and whether or not what's listed on the
bottle matches what's actually contained
in those formulations and despite those
formulations coming from quite reliable
quote unquote or thought to be reliable
sources it was found that these
supplements contain anywhere from 15
percent
of what's
thought to be or is told to be in those
supplements or
many times more melatonin than is listed
on the bottle so the dosaging does not
seem to be consistent with what's often
listed on the bottle and this is even
true within some of the more reputable
Brands so that's a real concern so we
need to highlight melatonin as perhaps
something that's only used occasionally
if you want to talk about dosages for
melatonin use for jet lag Etc go to
examine.com there's some excellent
references to studies there just put
melatonin into the search function it'll
tell you everything you need to know
about melatonin but now you know my
stance on melatonin one question I often
get about supplementation for sleep is
does it create a dependency that's an
excellent question to ask
I think most people
worry about even fear relying on
something so heavily that if they did
not have it for whatever reason that
they couldn't sleep
in my experience there is no problem
falling and staying asleep in the
absence of a supplement for sleep even
if you've been taking that supplement
for sleep
consistently seven days a week for
months and months maybe even years on
end I confess that I occasionally fall
asleep having not taken my pre-sleep
supplements and I happen to take
magnesium three and eight theanine and
epigenin I also take inositol it greatly
enhances my sleep and there have been
nights when I've fallen asleep not
having taken any of those things and
I've slept fine that said if I were to
explore multiple nights of trying to
sleep without that supplementation I
find that my sleep is not as good I'm
still able to fall asleep but the depth
of my sleep and the duration of my sleep
is not as good as when I'm supplementing
so I think that's
refreshing news at least to me that
there isn't a dependence on these
supplements in order to be able to fall
asleep it's not the same sort of
dependence that people experience from
things like sleeping pills that said
any compound any compound can create a
placebo type effect where we think we
need something in order to achieve a
certain effect we had a guest on this
podcast
some time ago Dr Ali Crum who's a
professor at Stanford and works on these
mindset effects belief effects and
Placebo effects and Placebo effects can
be very real and in some sense dovetail
with any conversation about dependency
meaning if you are somebody who loves
your sleep supplements and sleeps great
with them and one night you discover you
don't have them or you can't access them
for whatever reason that can create a
little bit of an anxiety around the idea
that oh in the in their absence you're
not going to be able to sleep and that's
a sort of a placebo effect in Reverse if
you will because what it suggests is
that there's a emotional or a cognitive
association with taking these things
that allows you to sleep well I would
highly recommend that people explore
this issue of dependency and Placebo
effects for Sleep supplements on their
own and under conditions in which
there's nothing pressing the next day
that is you don't have a big
presentation
Etc so what I recommend is that every
two weeks or so maybe every month or so
take one night off completely from all
your sleep supplements or leave out one
sleep supplement try to understand to
what extent you might have established a
dependency either real or Placebo based
on these sleep supplements and again I
suggest doing this on perhaps a Friday
night so that you know it's a weekend
the next day so you don't have to work
if perhaps you don't sleep well I think
what you'll find is what most people
find and that's
in the absence of taking your supplement
stack for Sleep one night you're still
gonna sleep just fine now does that mean
that these supplements are not actually
working under normal conditions where
you're taking them each night no what
this means is that many of these things
magnesiums in particular can build up in
the body and brain in a way that can be
beneficial and what probably explains
the fact that you can still sleep if you
miss a night of taking them is that the
neural circuits that are involved in
turning off thinking or in not thinking
and falling asleep those neural circuits
undergo what's called plasticity in
other words if you get better at falling
and staying asleep over time even if you
got better at that through the
Assistance or with the assistance of
some supplement or combination of
supplements well then those circuits are
still going to function just fine even
in the absence of not taking those
supplements just once we'll get back
into this conversation a little bit
later when we talk about cognitive
enhancement and focus
it's the same story there where indeed
there are things that people can take in
stimulant form and non-stimulant form
that can enhance cognitive ability and
focus but that does not mean that you
become so dependent on those that you
can't focus unless you take them this
has been shown multiple times over so
again to answer the question is there a
dependency established by taking
supplements for sleep
the short answer is no with the caveat
that Placebo effects and belief effects
are always going to be at play whether
or not you're talking about
supplementation prescription drugs or
even behavioral protocols for that
matter I'd like to take a brief break
and acknowledge our sponsor athletic
greens athletic greens is an all-in-one
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that
also contains digestive enzymes and
adaptogens I started taking athletic
Greens Way back in 2012 so that's 10
years now of taking athletic greens
every single day so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring this podcast the
reason I started taking athletic greens
and the reason I still take athletic
greens is that it covers all of my
foundational nutritional needs so
whether or not I'm eating well or enough
or not I'm sure that I'm covering all of
my needs for vitamins minerals
probiotics adaptogens to combat stress
and the digestive enzymes really help my
digestion I just feel much better when
I'm drinking athletic greens if you'd
like to try athletic greens you can go
to athleticgreens.com huberman and for
the month of January they have a special
offer where they'll give you 10 free
travel packs plus a year's supply of
vitamin D3 K2 vitamin D3 and K2 are
vital for immune function metabolic
function Hormone Health but also calcium
regulation and heart health again that's
athletic greens.com huberman to claim
their special offer in the month of
January of 10 free travel packs plus a
year supply of vitamin D3 K2 the next
category of supplementation that I'd
like to talk about is hormone support
improving or so-called optimizing your
hormones is a critical aspect of mental
health physical health and performance
we've done multiple episodes about
hormones including testosterone and
estrogen
for both men and women and for people of
different ages we've also had episodes
on thyroid hormone growth hormone and so
on you can find all those at
hubermanlab.com in fact you can go to
the hubermanlab.com website there's a
search function where you can just put
in a keyword and it will take you to all
the episodes and specific time points
where that topic happens to be covered
now Hormone Health is such an important
topic to discuss in the context of
supplementation because
indeed there are compounds that are
non-prescription based so-called
supplements that can improve hormone
function again anytime we are discussing
a particular aspect of mental health
physical health or performance we need
to start with a mention of the few
behavioral tools and nutrition-based
tools or at least some top Contour
coverage of those in a way that frames
up the discussion about supplementation
appropriately
so in the context of hormone support and
augmentation and optimization
if you are not getting adequate calories
from high quality sources
hormones like testosterone and estrogen
will suffer this is one of the reasons
why women will stop having their periods
if they're not ingesting enough calories
this is one of the reasons why
testosterone levels will drop if people
are not ingesting enough calories in
fact on the episode with expert guest
and medical doctor Peter attia he
described how sex hormone binding
globulin this is a protein that's
present in males and females that binds
to testosterone and other hormones and
prevents it from being in its free form
which is the more active form well
insulin which of course is going to
increase after the ingestion of
carbohydrates in particular insulin
actually inhibits or reduces sex hormone
binding globulin what this means is that
for you intermittent fasters or people
that are ingesting very few
carbohydrates or have very low blood
glucose or perhaps are taking things
like metformin or berberine which is a
supplement based approach to reducing
blood glucose well your sex hormone
binding globulin is going to increase
dramatically conversely if you are
eating enough calories in the form of
foods that allow your insulin to be a
bit higher not excessively High we hope
but a bit higher well then sex hormone
bonding globulin will go down and free
testosterone will go up so the
discussion about hormone support and
augmentation has to include some nod
toward or understanding of the fact that
nutrition and the way that nutrition
impacts hormones and the way that
hormones such as insulin impact other
hormones such as free testosterone that
all has to be acknowledged that is not
the topic of today's discussion but it's
important that I remind everybody that
nutrition matters for General hormone
status
it's also important to remember that
behaviors matter for hormone status
getting morning sunlight increases
cortisol levels cortisol levels are very
important to have elevated early in the
day for focus and alertness and for
immune function and to make sure that
cortisol levels are low at night and
thereby levels of growth hormone and
testosterone which is secreted mainly in
the early morning can be elevated at
night and in the early morning so
getting morning sunlight getting
strenuous exercise in the form of both
cardiovascular exercise but also
relatively short meaning an hour or less
bouts
of intense resistance training a few
times per week can also dramatically
alter hormone profiles in fact in the
episode that we did with Dr Duncan
French again you find that episode at
hubermanlab.com he described a very
strenuous but still brief two day a week
protocol of using resistance training
specifically to increase testosterone
and free testosterone and growth hormone
and so on
so nutrition matters exercise matters
when it comes to increasing supporting
or augmenting different hormones and
that's just the discussion about
testosterone free testosterone and
estrogen there's also the vast
discussion about thyroid hormone Etc
again we've covered all those topics in
previous episodes but once those
behavioral
tools are in place once you're doing the
right things and you're avoiding the
wrong things
doing the right things to support your
hormones and avoiding the things that
diminish hormones in the ways that can
be detrimental
once your nutrition is in place to
support your hormones then it makes
sense to turn and consider what
supplements can support hormones but I
do believe that you want to get your
behaviors and your nutrition correct
before you start thinking about
supplementation for hormones again I'll
repeat that get your nutrition and your
behaviors correct
for sake of hormones and for other
health purposes before you start
thinking about supplementation for
hormones and certainly before you start
thinking about prescription-based
approaches to improving hormones
once all of those other elements are in
place
the supplements that make sense in terms
of augmenting hormones come in two forms
one are broadband support for multiple
hormones and then the others are
supplements that are designed to
increase or in some cases decrease
specific hormones or hormone Pathways so
let's consider each of those in tandem
there are certain supplements things
like Sheila G for instance something
from ayurvedic medicine which may mainly
uh has the active ingredient fulvic acid
which is known to for instance increase
things like FSH follicle stimulating
hormone which in women is going to
increase certain aspects of egg growth
hence the name follicle stimulating
hormone it's going to stimulate certain
aspects of fertility it's Pro fertile
and in males can make for more sperm
production or more motile sperm FSH is
also going to indirectly increase
testosterone in males it's known to
increase libido in both males and
females so things like shilaji can
indeed augment multiple hormones and
support multiple hormone systems
generally in the direction of
pro-fertility pro libido and increasing
estrogen and testosterone
now there are other supplements such as
ashwagandha that also fall into this
category of affecting multiple hormones
ashwagandha is a very potent
supplement in terms of reducing cortisol
levels it has also been shown to
increase testosterone levels but
probably indirectly and that's because
cortisol and testosterone sort of exist
on a seesaw in terms of Pathways they're
on separate Pathways but those Pathways
interact enough that when cortisol is
lowered in general testosterone tends to
increase now it is important that with
certain hormones like ashwagandha that
you don't take them for more than two
weeks at a time at high dosages if you
want to know more of the specifics
around ashwagandha and how long to take
it how to cycle it Etc
please see our episode on Master stress
please also see the examine.com website
and put in ashwagandha it will get into
some of that description
but
Sheila G ashwagandha and things for
instance like L-Carnitine a supplement
that we often discuss in terms of
fertility because it can indeed improve
sperm motility and quality and egg
quality so it's a pro fertile compound
but it also impacts various
mitochondrial Pathways so it's having a
more indirect effect on hormones there
are many other
compounds present and available
supplements that are purported to be
pro-hormone support in particular for
testosterone or estrogen fertility and
libido there is a description for
instance of things like maca root maca
root can increase libido it's
found to be particularly effective in
women but in men as well and in all
people who are suffering from lower
libido due to intake of ssris selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors for
whatever reason ssris are used to treat
OCD they're used to treat depression any
number of different things maca root can
be in many instances effective in
increasing libido it does that however
through augmentation of dopamine related
Pathways and some of the hormone
Pathways Upstream of testosterone and
estrogen the reports that Maca increases
testosterone
are somewhat scant and a little bit weak
to be honest so it's having these
indirect effects that may impact
testosterone Downstream so again I'd put
Maca alongside ashwagandha alongside
shilaji as
supplements that are impacting multiple
hormone Pathways toward increased libido
increased fertility increased
testosterone or estrogen likely through
indirect pathways
now with all that said I'd like to
provide some examples of
supplements that work more directly on
specific hormone Pathways aimed at
achieving more specific goals such as
elevated testosterone or elevated free
testosterone or elevated growth hormone
for that matter and elevated thyroid
hormone I'd like to talk about growth
hormone first because it's actually a
pretty short discussion first of all the
best way to augment growth hormone is to
get quality deep sleep especially the
sleep that occurs in the first three or
four hours of the night is when growth
hormone is released and it's going to be
beneficial to avoid caloric intake in
the two hours preceding sleep again
don't go to bed so hungry that you wake
up an hour or an hour and a half later
or you have trouble falling asleep but
avoiding food intake in the two hours
prior to sleep and certainly avoiding
alcohol and cannabis is going to
facilitate growth hormone release in the
first hours of sleep many people use
intermittent fasting or even longer
periods of fasting to increase growth
hormone
one of the interesting things I learned
from an expert guest Dr Kyle Gillette
who's a medical doctor
on this podcast is that indeed while
lengthy or fast or intermittent fasting
can increase growth hormone levels very
substantially it has indirect effects on
the genetic Pathways and The receptors
for growth hormone that actually are
detrimental for the function of growth
hormone so avoiding food for the two
hours prior to bedtime is a good idea if
you avoid food for longer that's just
going to assist even more certainly
isn't going to hurt in terms of growth
hormone release but extended fast
specifically for the purpose of
increasing growth hormone
are not really logical when you look at
the broader effects of extended fast
that is not to say that extended fasting
is not appropriate for some people it
can be in certain instances or that
intermittent fasted so-called time
restricted feeding is not beneficial for
some people it can be here I'm only
referring to the effects or in this case
the lack of effects of intermittent
fasting time restricted feeding on
growth hormones specifically now in
terms of supplements to increase growth
hormone there are very few supplements
that have been shown to augment this
pathway there is some idea that Arginine
supplementation prior to bedtime can
further Elevate levels of growth hormone
especially when fasted that literature
is rather weak to be honest I encourage
you to go to examine.com if you want to
peruse those particular studies
really the things that increase growth
hormone very potently fall outside the
realm of supplementation they include
exercise again look at the Duncan French
episode or
in the Kyle Gillette episode on
optimizing hormones in males in
particular but this also pertains to
females that avoiding food two hours
prior to bedtime really can boost growth
hormone significantly in sleep beyond
what it would be otherwise but it's
really only once you get into the realm
of prescription compounds things like
peptides like sermorelin which increase
igf-1 and growth hormone things like
growth hormone Itself by prescription if
and only if it's prescribed by a doctor
of course and is safe for you that's
when you start getting into really
significant increases in growth hormone
not a lot of supplements out there to
increase growth hormone potently now
it's a different story when you start
thinking about and talking about
testosterone and free testosterone and
luteinizing hormone luteinizing hormone
is released from the pituitary which is
this gland
not far from the roof of your mouth and
its nearby neighbor the hypothalamus is
a collection of neurons that sits above
the roof of your mouth and talks to the
pituitary talks to it through neural
connections and hormone-based
connections there is a hormone called
GnRH gonadotropin releasing hormone that
is released from the hypothalamus into
the pituitary it stimulates the release
of luteinizing hormone or LH which then
travels in the bloodstream to impact
multiple tissues in the body but mainly
the ovary in females and the testes and
males to stimulate estrogen production
and testosterone production there are
supplements that can potently increase
GnRH
and or luteinizing a hormone and then
indirectly increase testosterone and
estrogen and I always like to remind
people testosterone and estrogen are
present in both males and females okay
and both are important for things like
libido muscle growth
and so on a lot of people think that oh
in males you know having very high
testosterone and low estrogen is
actually ideal it's actually not ideal
if you want to keep your libido anything
that lowers your estrogen too far is
going to reduce your libido you don't
want estrogen too high but you also do
not want it too low so supplements that
can tickle this pathway or actually can
act as a bit more of a directed hammer
on this luteinizing hormone pathway may
also impact GnRH are things like fedojia
agrestis this is an herb
that I've talked about before on the
podcast that when taken at dosages of
600 milligrams per day many people not
all report elevated levels of libido
elevated sperm production elevated
testosterone in some cases elevated
estrogen a bunch of hormones Downstream
of luteinizing hormone now are you going
to be a fedojia agrestis responder or a
non-responder there's simply no way to
know except by trying it if you are
going to go down this route
there are two very important
considerations first of all there's a
fairly extensive literature on the fact
that fidoji agrestis can be toxic to
testicular cells and perhaps other cells
when taken at very high dosages so
obeying the particular dosages of
fedogio aggressus that are recommended
on various product labels and cycling
for doji Augustus can be important some
people need to cycle it eight weeks on
two weeks off other people opt for 12
weeks on a month off I know a few people
who have taken it continuously with no
issues but I do want to suggest caution
when taking fidochio agrestis
the cautionary notes are stay within the
recommended dosage ranges you can go
lower but certainly don't go higher and
I think it is wise to cycle every eight
weeks or so to come off it for two weeks
and then going back on if that's your
choice if you feel it benefited you
or taking it for 12 week periods of time
and then cycling off for a full month
before repeating again
the best way to know whether or not
fedojia or any of these other
supplements is impacting your hormone
levels in the direction that you want
and not impacting your hormone levels or
other aspects of your biology in ways
that you don't want is from a blood test
there is simply no better tool to
evaluate whether or not these
supplements are working to support your
hormones in the ways that you want and
not causing issues
except to take a blood test this podcast
has inside tracker as a sponsor that can
do in-home blood tests and give you
blood panels there are other sources of
blood tests that are quite good as well
of course and in the first episode of
The huberman Lab podcast that I did with
Dr Kyle Gillette again a medical doctor
expert in hormones diabetes and various
other aspects of medicine he described
and it is time stamped how to stand the
best probability of getting your
insurance to cover a blood test how to
talk to your doctor about getting a
hormone panel and so on so I'll refer
you to that episode for that but blood
tests are going to be very important I
recommend taking them before adding in
any supplement to increase
hormones of any kind or decreased
hormones of any kind for that matter and
then again after about four to eight
weeks of taking that particular
supplement in order to evaluate whether
or not it worked and whether or not it
had any negative effects that you would
like to avoid
I also wanted to remind people of the
dosage conversation that we had earlier
just because there's a recommended
dosage of fedogio agrestis of say 600
milligrams per day
first of all that is not an invitation
to take twice as much and expect twice
the positive effects that is not a good
approach especially with something like
fedogiograstis which can at high dosages
be toxic but it's also important to
perhaps consider taking a lower dosage
and seeing how that affects your
hormones
that approach requires a bit more
patience I know most people are thinking
I want the effect and I want it now but
I think it's very important when
thinking about exercise your nutrition
or supplementation to really play the
long game to think about what's going to
work for you in the immediate end in the
long term and to ease into any kind of
supplement regimen for instance by
taking one thing at a time varying One
supplement out and One supplement in
starting at minimal effective dose and
build up your protocols over a year or
several years it really can be
beneficial I can say for myself I
started exploring the supplement space
and taking different supplements in
different combination
and alone evaluating which ones worked
and did not work for me some were
absolutely dreadful for me I have tons
of stories about supplement fail some of
which were just kind of innocuous
meaning they were a waste of money which
isn't innocuous but at least it wasn't
detrimental to my health other
supplements which fortunately don't
exist on the market anymore
um I think actually uh were quite
dangerous and I feel lucky that I did
not experience even greater negative
effects from them other supplements have
been tremendously useful for me and for
other people for things like sleep and
hormone support focus and so on so for
Doja gracias is a good example of a
supplement that is known to have potent
effects but you need to approach it with
the appropriate um I would say respect
for the fact that the dosage ranges in
which it works
um have to be kept pretty narrow without
causing issues
it does increase luteinizing hormone and
thereby testosterone and estrogen so if
you're somebody who's already
excessively high in one or the other
it's going to be very hard to just
direct it to only testosterone or only
estrogen now the topic of today's
episode is not about fedoji Augustus per
se I highlight it because it is one of
the more potent
supplements for sake of hormone
augmentation but it's still fairly
Broadband it's a little more specific
than something like shilaji but it's
still fairly Broadband in terms of
hitting multiple endpoint hormones
testosterone and estrogen and maybe some
other hormones as well
there are other supplements in
particular Tonga Ali which is known to
for instance increase libido whether or
not it does that by way of augmenting
dopamine related Pathways or
testosterone Pathways still isn't clear
it is known to increase free
testosterone by reducing sex hormone
binding globulin
Tonga Ali can be beneficial both for men
and for women
in dosages anywhere from 200 milligrams
to 600 milligrams per day so there I
would say scale according to body size
although start with the minimum amount
and find the minimal effective dose for
you again blood work is going to be the
most effective way to determine what's
working or not working at the level of
objective numbers but subjective
experience matters too you know if you
take it at 400 milligrams for four weeks
and you don't notice any effect you
might try it at 600 milligrams but not
higher and if you still don't see an
effect well then it doesn't appear to
have worked for you other people
experience dramatic effects from things
like fedoja and Tonga Ali why would that
be the case well if you look to the
scientific literature what you find is
that the studies that report the biggest
effects of any supplement usually start
with a population that somehow
diminished or back on its heels in one
particular Dimension so for instance
people that are hypogonadal that are not
making enough testosterone or free
testosterone in fact their levels are
very very low they're subclinical
off range in terms of the charts
below the normal
well those people when they take
supplements like Tonga Ali fedoja tend
to experience greater effects because
they're starting from a lower level than
people who perhaps are close to the
optimal levels achieved through either
age genetics exercise nutrition or some
combination of those so that's an
important thing to think about these are
called floor effects and sealing effects
ceiling effects are for instance if an
individual already has very high
testosterone and free testosterone and
they take a supplement to increase it
further they might not see any increase
whereas somebody who sits more in the
middle to low range stands to experience
a much greater increase in fact one
individual I know who took Tonga Ali
admittedly on my recommendation his
testosterone was initially very low and
he was having a number of different
symptoms he did blood work he that's how
he knew it was low and he then took
Tonga Ali and fedoja in combination
because he decided he just wanted
results he didn't care which What which
thing was going to give him the results
and he experienced big increases in
testosterone this would be not free but
total testosterone of he experienced as
much as 600 nanograms per deciliter
increase from where he was before which
is very dramatic it was a near tripling
of where his testosterone had started
off to where he ended up I don't know if
he's ever done the experiment of
removing fidojia or Tonga to find out
which one it was and this is why many
people just take them in combination and
if you have the budget for it and you
are interested in just finding what
works but not isolating what works at
the level of single ingredients that
would be the approach I recommend
however again I think most people do
well to figure out which specific
ingredients are going to work best for
them by isolating the variables the way
I've described repeatedly throughout
this episode to my knowledge Tonga Ali
does not need to be cycled meaning you
don't have to take periods of time off
from it I should note that the effects
of Tonga Ali can take a little bit
longer to experience so perhaps blood
work should be done 8 to 12 weeks after
initiating the Tonga Ali protocol
as opposed to earlier and it does seem
to have sort of cumulative effects on
libido and that points to the likelihood
that it's having some impact on neural
Pathways as opposed to hormone Pathways
hormone Pathways can be slow but in
general
neural pathways are the ones that are
going to explain slow Rising shifts in
any kind of physical or mental aspect
that then remains stable over time so
the exact effects of Tonga Ali and where
meaning where they arise in the brain
and body aren't known I will provide a
link to a really beautiful review
article that covers the literature on
tonganali this came out fairly recently
and that I've reviewed with a number of
other
um MDS and medical or medicine related
podcasters it's a really nice review
I'll provide a link to that gives a
survey of Tonga Ali what people are
discovering what they're finding what
they're not finding and so forth as a
final note on supplements for hormone
augmentation and supplementation I want
to make a brief mention of something
specifically related to female Health
which is of course the menstrual cycle
and across the menstrual cycle different
hormones are present at different levels
follicle stimulating hormone is very
high during the so-called follicular
phase right and then you have your
luteal phase we have an entire episode
coming up about female hormones and
Hormone Health that will cover this we
also covered a little bit of this in the
other episodes on testosterone and
estrogen but the point I'd like to make
now is that for women
they should fully expect that certain
supplements not all but certain
supplements because of the way they
impact different hormones would have
different effects maybe even opposite
effects at different phases of the
menstrual cycle and for that reason I
believe it is especially important
to have tight control over dosage and
individual ingredients in your
supplement regimen so for instance if
you're somebody who takes Sheila Gene I
know many women who take Sheila G or
Tonga Ali
for instance or Maca and you find that
it really serves you well that is it
provides the mental and physical
benefits that you want and enjoy
at certain phases of your menstrual
cycle but at other phases of your
menstrual cycle it feels like too much
or it actually can start to give you
negative mental or physical effects well
then obviously having control over those
specific ingredients is going to be
extremely important so that you can
titrate the dosage or increase the
dosage as the case may be or cease
taking those things entirely at certain
phases of your menstrual cycle
that's not to say that some women can't
just continuously take these supplements
throughout their menstrual cycle some
can but some find that that makes them
very uncomfortable or that they would do
well to alter different ingredients at
different phases of their cycle so again
this speaks to the critical importance
of single ingredient control dosage
control and the ability to cease taking
individual or multiple ingredients
according to the backdrop of your health
generally and obviously the menstrual
cycle is a profound shift in the
hormones and thus the entire biological
and psychological milieu that exists in
the body and of course there's the issue
of birth control and whether or not
people are taking hormone-based birth
control certain forms of hormone-based
birth control and women involve
tonically elevating that means
consistently elevating estrogen that's
certainly going to reduce the
fluctuations and thus the probability
that certain hormones and hormone
Pathways will change across the
menstrual cycle but not eliminate it
altogether also there's the key issue of
fertility in both males and females one
important note even though this is not
an episode about fertility we're going
to have one soon but the important point
about fertility is that there are
supplements not just Sheila G but there
are supplements and supplement protocols
such as
L-Carnitine in particular injectable
L-Carnitine which does require a
prescription at least in the US but also
orally ingested L-Carnitine that can
improve sperm health and motility and
egg health and motility I mentioned that
earlier
but if couples are trying to conceive
it is important that if you're going to
take something that is a supplement
directed towards sperm and or egg Health
that you also consider how that
interfaces with some of the other
hormone-based
compounds that is prescription drugs
that you may be taking this is true for
people who are doing IVF in vitro
fertilization or not
again that entire discussion will be
handled in our episode on fertility and
on female hormone health and we already
did the episode with Dr Kyle Gillette on
male hormone Health optimization the
next category of supplementation that
I'd like to address is supplements
related to cognitive enhancement and
focus and here there are a number of
very useful strategies that one could
take I'd like to divide this
conversation into two general categories
of supplements to address cognitive
enhancement and focus the first category
are supplements that increase energy by
way of stimulant properties so the most
obvious of these is caffeine caffeine is
of course a molecule that can increase
levels of alertness it also can increase
levels of focus provided that dosages
are in the appropriate range the
appropriate range in most cases is going
to be one to three milligrams per
kilogram of body weight taken
30 minutes or so before any kind of
mental or physical Endeavor we did an
entire episode about caffeine where you
can learn lots of facts about caffeine
how best to utilize caffeine and indeed
I'll just give you a few of those now
turns out that if your regular caffeine
user you can still derive the cognitive
enhancing and focus enhancing effects of
caffeine if you ingest caffeine every
day but if you were to take two days off
from caffeine completely and right now I
hear all the caffeine addicts out there
just kind of cringing at the idea and
then take caffeine in the 30 minutes
prior to some especially important event
physical or mental event where you
really need to focus and be able to
sustain that Focus for long periods of
time it would have an even greater
effect than it normally would but since
most people are taking caffeine in a
kind of ongoing regular way I just want
to emphasize that it still has Pro
cognitive and pro-focus effects even if
it's taken every day or even multiple
times per day again a cautionary note
don't drink caffeine too late in the day
past 2 p.m it can really start to impede
uh your sleep at night even if you can
fall asleep at night the architecture of
that sleep is not going to be great if
you're ingesting caffeine in the
preceding eight to ten and even 12 hours
and that actually raises another
tangential but still important point so
I'm going to make it and then get back
to supplements which is the best
cognitive enhancer that you will ever
take is a really good night's sleep of
sufficient duration okay so sleep is
going to be the Bedrock of your ability
to focus and remember things in fact
it's during sleep that neural
connections remodel so-called
neuroplasticity it's actually not when
you trigger learning but it's when you
consolidate and reinforce learning and a
number of other things that relate to
cognitive enhancement and focus the
other thing of course is that you're
going to need to have sufficient levels
of nutrition so you don't want to be
overly hungry or it's going to be hard
to focus nor do you want to be
overloaded with calories or a volume of
food or have your blood glucose to be so
high that it's going to make you sleepy
there's a reason why when discussing
stress and the so-called autonomic
nervous system that the phrase rest and
digest comes into play rest and digest
as the name implies relates to the fact
that when we have
a lot of food in our gut it tends to
make us sleepy in other words it's hard
for us to focus and it's hard for us to
maintain cognitive attention and
remember things Etc so there are a bunch
of Behavioral tools for enhancing Focus
we did an entire episode on enhancing
focus it does touch on supplementation
again you can find links to that in all
formats at hubermanlab.com we also have
a newsletter related to this topic also
at hubermanlab.com at zero cost
with all of that said and in particular
the Highlight about sleep being the best
way to enhance your cognitive abilities
and focus anytime we're having a
discussion about supplements for
enhancing cognitive ability and focus a
major category of those supplements is
going to fall into the stimulant
category and that's going to include
most often caffeine although there are
other sources of stimulants I'm not
going to touch on those for the moment
just talk about caffeine when people
hear caffeine they think well I can just
drink coffee and indeed that's a great
source of caffeine so is yerba mate I
would caution people to
um if you're going to use yerba mate for
whatever purpose caffeine or otherwise
that you avoid the smoked versions of
yerba mate they are carcinogenic that is
the smoked versions or carcinogenic I
know and to consume the non-smoked uh
varieties
um instead the important thing to
understand about caffeine is that while
it can be ingested in the form of a
drink or an energy drink to your coffee
it can also be ingested as a pure
supplement that is there are caffeine
supplements and I know a number of
people including a very very prominent
podcaster whose name I won't mention who
drinks herbal tea but takes a 100 to 300
milligram tablet of caffeine with the
herbal tea so in that case it is no
longer herbal tea it is caffeinated
herbal tea
when you take caffeine in pill form it
tends to have a much more potent and
long lasting effect than when you take
caffeine in
the form of coffee or tea it's actually
a world apart in terms of its effects
and if you haven't experienced this
before it might be something that you
want to explore it might not be
something you want to explore in
particular if you're somebody who
experiences anxiety or panic attacks be
very careful with your intake of
caffeine again see the episode of the
huberman law podcast all about caffeine
for more on that but
it is the case that even 100 milligrams
of caffeine in tablet form I suppose it
could be in capsule form as well but in
its pure form leads to much greater
enhancement of alertness and focus then
does often the comparable amount or even
twice the amount of caffeine contained
in coffee or tea now why would that be
has a lot to do with the other things
that are in coffee and tea so here I'm
not encouraging people to become reliant
on caffeine capsules or on caffeine
tablets but if you want to increase
alertness and focus caffeine is a potent
way to do that it works the other
category of stimulant that can work in
terms of enhancing alertness and focus
are going to be things that increase
adrenaline in some other way or
epinephrine as it's also called
adrenaline epinephrine same thing in
some other way that are going to
touch into or augment the so-called
adrenergic and adrenaline systems and
there are things like yohimbine and
different forms of yohimbine like Alpha
yohimbine
um there are multiple forms of these
things now I would go to examine.com to
explore the different forms of your
himbine about 10 20 years ago yohimbine
was marketed primarily as a pro libido
and pro-erectile agent turns out it has
very low efficacy for both of those
things but there are certain forms of
yohimbine that act as stimulants
that are effective and are separate from
those claims and Pathways one particular
form is called Alpha yohimbine it
sometimes goes by the name raulstein and
that's spelled
r-a-u-w-o-l-s-c-i-n-e again that's Alpha
yohimbine and it's used as a stimulant
often to also promote fat loss and
alertness I have to say that it's a very
potent and somewhat
um precarious supplement some people
experience a lot of anxiety on it that
could also be because they tend to take
it on either an empty stomach or in
combination with sub caloric diets it's
a it's sort of getting out on the edge
of things that for some people can work
not so well for other people they might
actually find it to be a very effective
stimulant in general in terms of
supplement based approaches to increase
cognitive
function and focus caffeine either in
coffee or tea form or in tablet or
capsule form but at lower dosages than
you would find in coffee and tea I think
is actually a reasonable way to explore
stimulant-based approaches
for enhancing cognitive function and
focus I mentioned all that not because I
think that you probably already didn't
know that caffeine can enhance alertness
and focus most people already know that
and I acknowledge that but rather as a
contrast point for the other supplement
based approach for increasing cognitive
function and focus which is
to increase certain neurotransmitter
Pathways that are not stimulant based so
for instance
Alpha GPC which is essentially a choline
donor acts in the pathways related to
the neuromodulator acetylcholine and can
enhance Focus so at dosages of anywhere
from 300 to 600 milligrams people
experience heightened levels of focus
for sake of mental work or physical work
the half-life of alpha GPC is about four
to six hours so it's relatively short
lasting although you wouldn't
necessarily want to take it right before
bed I don't recommend that it is not a
stimulant it tends to enhance focus by
augmenting acetylcholine and
acetylcholine Pathways specifically now
it does create a little bit of an
increase in alertness
so some people actually perceive it
subjectively as an increase in
overall stimulation but it's different
than a caffeine type stimulant so for
instance 300 milligrams to 600
milligrams of alpha GPC taken alone will
allow people to be more focused but
doesn't tend to make people feel jittery
or over stimulated
similarly
500 milligrams to a thousand milligrams
or somewhere in between of something
like l-tyrosine which is amino acid
precursor to dopamine a different
neuromodulator taken a loan or in
conjunction with again I believe in
separating these things out by product
but I suppose you could take Alpha GPC
NL tyrosine together if you had already
tried them separately and decide they
worked well for you then you decide to
combine them what people tend to
experience is that the cholinergic
stimulation from alpha GPC and the
dopaminergic stimulation from l-tyrosine
or simply l-tyrosine alone or Alpha GPC
alone leads to increased levels of focus
without the kind of overall feelings of
stimulant-based alertness that one would
experience with caffeine and indeed or I
should say of course there are products
out there and there are people out there
that combine all three of these things
together caffeine Alpha GPC and
l-tyrosine and while I'm not suggesting
that's a good or a bad thing I would
suggest that anytime you start to
explore the cognitive enhancing effects
and the focus enhancing effects of any
supplement that you ask which ones are
stimulants so for instance caffeine and
Alpha human being
which ones tend to tap more into
neuromodulator systems like Alpha GPC
and l-tyrosine and to separate those out
conceptually because whereas things like
Alpha yohim binding caffeine will mostly
serve the role of increasing levels of
alertness but not tightening your focus
things like Alpha GPC and l-tyrosine
tend to serve the role of less elevation
and alertness but more tightening of
focus and this of course is why people
often stack these and take them in
combination so I think it's a very
important distinction that most people
aren't aware of and I'm not here to tell
you that the stimulant-based approach or
the neuromodulator based approach is
better or worse they are simply
different from one another although I
will say that I think it is important to
explore them separately if indeed you're
going to explore any of them before you
would start to combine them in a single
formula again individual ingredients are
going to be the way to go in terms of
figuring out what's best for you if
anything some people may find that even
the slightest bit of caffeine or even
the slightest spit of alpha GPC or
l-tyrosine just places them into a state
of mind and or body that's just
uncomfortable and not
compatible with the kind of work that
they want to do whereas other people
searching myself
regularly rely on taking 300 milligrams
of alpha GPC it turns out more than that
kind of doesn't work for me or it tends
to send my mind down a pathway that I
don't like to be in for sake of
cognitive work but I will routinely take
300 milligrams of alpha GPC prior to
some cognitive work or prior to a
workout I do often combine that with
some caffeine not in capsule or pill
form but rather in the form of cup of
coffee or yerba mate and it turns out
that for me just by way of example
l-tyrosine is something that works very
powerfully to elevate my level of focus
but that I tend to crash pretty hard
afterward and so I tend to error away
from l-tyrosine but some people tolerate
it really well and actually really like
it I rely on something else for dopamine
augmentation which is
phenylethylamine which is a little bit
more short lasting again I arrived at
these protocols for myself by mixing and
matching but mostly by trying individual
ingredients alone before combining them
into any sort of cocktail before taking
them you for a workout or before a
cognitive work bout and I suggest that
you explore them in the same way because
that's going to deliver you to the best
possible protocols for you which only
you can determine and then of course
there's the category of supplements that
can support cognitive function and focus
but that also touch on other General
functions related to brain and body
Health such as metabolic Health mood Etc
and the one that comes to mind here are
the omega-3 fatty acids I've talked a
lot about omega-3 fatty acids that are
available in the form of foods so for
instance fatty ocean fish there's
certain plant-based sources for these as
well certain algaes and things of that
sort touched on this in the episodes on
depression that I've done
but
this topic mainly comes up around the
issue of fish oil fish oil capsules and
liquid and this is a discussion I think
is worth having
early on in the episode we talked about
foundational nutrition and supplements
that include a bunch of different
ingredients we touched on the idea that
some people might have the budget to
take one such product or any number of
different products that combine all
those ingredients
I should say that for those that are
interested in taking a supplement
but have a lower budget than would allow
for taking one of those General
categories of supplements we talked
about earlier for foundational nutrition
that combines everything vitamins
minerals probiotics prebiotics
adaptogens digestive enzymes
I do think that there's a category of
supplements that can greatly enhance the
probability of offsetting depression and
maybe even improve mood directly or
indirectly there's evidence for what I'm
about to tell you within the scientific
literature and or offset the amount of
antidepressant medication that people
need to take that's also been
demonstrated and improve metabolic
function cardiovascular function
and also
enhance our ability to do focused work
and here I'm referring to the so-called
omega-3 essential fatty acids in
particular the omega-3 form of the
essential fatty acids there's now a lot
of data showing that ingesting one to
three grams of EPA in particular
in the form of either fish oil capsules
or liquid can be beneficial for a number
of different aspects of brain and body
health and can enhance
focus and cognitive ability
this is especially true in developing
brains and there's actually an extensive
data out of a laboratory at University
of California Santa Barbara talking
about how mothers who supplement
Omega-3s in particular the epas although
they also need to get the dhas
that leads to Greater brain weights and
health of Offspring this is something we
will definitely explore in a future
episode likely with an expert guest
who's doing that work in that laboratory
at UC Santa Barbara
the point here is that if somebody has a
limited budget to purchase supplements
and cannot afford a foundational
supplement in the sort that we talked
about earlier athletic greens are
similar but they do have a budget that
would allow them to purchase a high
quality Omega-3
fatty acid fish oil that would and to
ingest it in quantity sufficient enough
to get above that one gram of EPA per
day again this is really important if
you look at the product labels you'll
often see you know 1500 or 1600
milligrams
of essential fatty acids but the key is
you get above that one gram of EPA per
day threshold and as high as three grams
per day we had a guest on this podcast
Dr Rhonda Patrick who takes anywhere
from I believe three to four maybe even
more grams of EPA per day for a variety
of reasons including some of the reasons
we're discussing now before we move on
to discussing some of the more Global
themes related to developing a rational
supplementation protocol
I do want to touch on this vast category
of supplementation that includes
food-based or food mimic type
supplements so this would be for
instance whey proteins or milk proteins
or egg proteins or plant proteins that's
a discussion that in and of itself
deserves an entire episode if you want
to understand which types of protein and
source of proteins are going to be the
most bioavailable the best for protein
synthesis for recovery from exercise
building muscle Etc I'd like to refer
you to a segment within the episode that
I did with Dr Lane Norton where he talks
about total protein needs per day it's
about one gram per pound of body weight
per day for most people although there's
some variation depending on activity Etc
and the quality of sourcing of those
various proteins is extremely important
and that of course leads to a discussion
about the quality and type of protein
that would be present in a supplement
like a whey protein supplement or casein
which is a milk protein based supplement
that discussion is segmented and time
stamped in the episode that I did with
them you can find at hubermanlab.com he
actually pointed to some interesting
data on potato protein as perhaps being
a great plant-based substitute for those
that don't want to take whey-based
protein but the fact that whey-based
proteins can be very useful for getting
to and above a protein threshold for all
sorts of reasons not just for muscle
building although it's great for that
but for other purposes as well
and that's about one category of
food-based or food mimic type
supplements there are for instance
branched chain amino acids there are for
instance green tea supplements there's a
huge landscape of this far too much for
us to get into in any kind of
um reasonable detail but I do want to
acknowledge that those all exist the key
thing to understand is that while they
can serve a great role in providing
replacement for meals that you perhaps
couldn't have consumed otherwise and
while they often are very convenient
because you can drink as opposed to eat
your calories I think that most people
would agree that
getting some significant fraction of
your nutrition from Whole Foods is going
to be useful for a variety of reasons in
particular the fiber that comes along
with it the bulk of the food that tends
to make us feel sated
and of course the fact that a lot of
vitamins and minerals and other things
that are contained within Foods as well
as essential fatty acids in foods like
animal-based proteins are not going to
be present in most if not all of those
kind of food mimic type powders and
replacements for food another point is
this question about
age-related effects so for instance
should kids be taking supplements well I
mentioned earlier that there's some
evidence that making sure that kids are
getting enough omega-3 fatty acids can
be beneficial they certainly could get
those from food-based sources just look
up online food-based sources of omega-3
fatty acids and epas and you'll see
lists there
some people choose to supplement on top
of that in particular in kids that are
developing very quickly
I regardless of whether or not they're
consuming enough epa's from food some
parents choose to supplement on top of
that I am personally not a fan of
children taking melatonin for the reason
that melatonin is already chronically
elevated in kids and there's a growing
body of literature that melatonin
supplementation in kids can be
potentially harmful I don't want to
create alarm among those who've already
been taking it or giving it to their
kids or that gave it to their kids in
the past but I do think that melatonin
in particular should be approached with
a lot of caution especially for kids and
then of course there's the issue of
whether or not all these other
supplements that we've discussed whether
or not kids can take them safely and
again it's highly individual I would say
that for the supplements that relate to
hormone augmentation and support
unless your physician a board-certified
MD specifically recommends them I would
strongly suggest avoiding intake of
those things until at least after
puberty and probably in to the late
teens and early 20s because the body and
brain are still developing and hormone
systems are still active even though
puberty may happen between ages you know
11 and 14 or even 15. puberty can be a
long lasting event with a long taper and
tail
on it so you want to be cautious about
augmenting hormones in young people
through the use of supplementation
unless a physician is working very
closely with you or rather you with them
and then in ages of say 22 years old 24
and older I don't see any reason why
people who are in their 50s or 60s would
have any different protocols than people
in their 30s and 40s except perhaps in
the domain of cognitive enhancement
where it might make sense again might
provide it it can be done safely and
with the consult of a physician
it might be beneficial for people who
are approaching their later years to
consider increasing dosages or the
variety of things and approaches that
they take for cognitive enhancement
because age-related cognitive decline is
a reality there is no person that
escapes that the question is whether or
not the slope of that decline is very
steep or very shallow and of course this
is an opportunity for me to raise the
point that I made much earlier and that
I'll make over and over again because it
really is the most important point to
today's discussion which is that
behaviors both exercise sleep making
sure that your relationship to light
getting sufficient sunlight early in the
day and throughout the day if you can
and limiting your viewing of bright
artificial light in the late evening and
especially between the hours of 10 pm
and 4 a.m things of that sort all the
do's and don'ts
and of course cardiovascular exercise
and resistance training exercise and
maybe even flexibility training exercise
topics we've covered extensively on this
podcast and for which we'll soon have a
special series airing with Dr Andy
Galpin that gets into a lot of detail
and protocol development that you can
all employ
all of that needs to be done at every
age certainly past puberty in order to
maximize cognitive function in order to
maximize cardiovascular function in
order to maximize focus and every aspect
that we really all stand to and want to
enhance when we think about
supplementation so again get your sleep
right do that by getting your
relationship to light right get your
exercise right Quality Social connection
right and then of course there's that
landscape of nutrition that we talked
about extensively earlier and for which
we have other episodes that really dive
deep including that episode or I should
say in particular that episode with Dr
Lane Norton where we really took a full
survey of the landscape of nutrition
everything from protein needs vitamins
minerals fiber microbiome it's a
deep deep discussion with a lot of
actionable takeaways if you're curious
about nutrition and in particular if
you're a vegan or vegetarian or
carnivore based but even for the more
common omnivores such as myself I found
that to be an incredible Learning
Journey thanks to Dr Lane Norton just so
much useful knowledge in that episode if
you want to learn more about nutrition
the behavioral tools the nutritional
tools are really going to serve as the
primary two layers upon which your
supplementation Protocols are going to
rest and again I want to emphasize that
your supplementation protocol may be
zero supplements it could include no
supplements whatsoever and that would be
perfectly fine provided that you're
sleeping as well as you want to and need
to you're able to focus and work as well
as you want to and need to you're able
to perform physically as well as you
want to and need to and you feel that
your hormones and related functions are
where you want them
however for most people
who are doing most everything right
they want to explore how they can make
things like their sleep their focus
their hormone function even better and
that's where supplementation makes a lot
of sense and when I say it makes a lot
of sense I mean it makes a lot of sense
to explore in a rational and regimented
way there are a couple of big themes
that we've talked about a few times
during today's podcast that I'd like to
reiterate now because they are so
crucial to developing a rational
supplementation protocol the most
important of which is unless we're
talking about foundational nutritional
support that is coverage of vitamins
minerals digestive enzymes probiotics
prebiotics and adaptogens
we should really be focusing on single
ingredient formulations foundational
supplements that include all those
things I just listed off all combined in
One supplement are fine I simply don't
see any other practical or reasonable
way to get each and every one of those
things through single ingredient
formulations however when you want to
start thinking about and actually
practically exploring things like
supplementation for sleep or Hormone
Health or cognitive function the single
ingredient formulations are going to
give you the most power and control
they're going to make sure that you can
find the minimal effective doses that
you can rule out things that are not
effective for you or that may be
detrimental for you in whatever fashion
and it's not just about cost
Effectiveness it's also about arriving
at small kits or cocktails of
supplements that you can really manage
and work with that you're not dependent
on but that you really feel can augment
the various aspects of your health that
are important to you so that's really
what today's episode is about even
though we had coverage of specific
supplements and their functions in these
different domains of mental and physical
health and performance today's episode
was really geared toward giving you
resources and a framework to think about
how to approach supplementation how to
navigate sticking points and pain points
in supplementation how to get the most
out of your supplementation regimen
without spending an excessive amount of
money and if you don't have finances to
allow for a lot of exploration of
supplements how to narrow in on the most
effective supplements the most quickly
and derive all the benefits that you can
from them and as a final point the that
is redundant with a few of the themes we
talked about today but that I don't
think I ever really explicitly stated is
that
while the word supplement makes it sound
like these compounds are something just
to add on top of or compensate for
deficiencies in nutrition or other areas
of your life many of them are actually
quite potent compounds these are potent
non-prescription
molecules that really can move the
needle in terms of your ability to think
more clearly sleep better support your
hormone function but as always they are
just one element within an ecosystem of
other factors such as your behaviors
which includes do's and don'ts such as
your nutrition maybe even such as
prescription drugs that you also might
happen to be taking or hoping to be
taking less of or removing completely
again that has to be done in discussion
with Physicians if you're going to do it
at all but
the real Point here is that what we call
supplements are actually a powerful gear
within a larger system aimed at each and
every one of us customizing tools for
our mental physical health and
performance if you're learning from and
or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zero cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on Apple and Spotify and on both
apple and Spotify you can leave us up to
a five-star review if you have questions
for us or topics you'd like me to cover
or guess that you'd like me to invite
onto the huberman Lab podcast please put
those in the comments section on YouTube
I do read all the comments also please
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast during today's podcast and on
many previous episodes of The huberman
Lab podcast we discuss supplements again
while supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people can derive
tremendous benefit from them we've
partnered with momentous supplements
because momentous supplements are of
extremely high quality they have single
ingredient formula relations and they
ship internationally because we know
many of you reside outside of the United
States if you'd like to learn more about
the supplements discussed on the
huberman Lab podcast please go to live
momentous spelled ous so that's
livemomentis.com huberman if you're not
already following us on social media we
are huberman lab on Instagram Twitter
Facebook and Linkedin and in particular
on Instagram I cover science and science
related tools some of which overlap with
the contents of the huberman Lab podcast
much of which is distinct however from
the contents of the huberman Lab podcast
again it's huberman lab on all social
media platforms and if you haven't
already subscribe to our neural network
newsletter it's a zero cost monthly
newsletter you simply sign up with your
email by going to hubermanlab.com the
newsletter includes summaries of podcast
episodes we have tool kits for Sleep
tool kits for Focus tool kits related to
deliberate cold exposure heat exposure
and much much more again all zero cost
you provide your email to sign up we do
not share your email with anybody there
are also sample newsletters there that
you don't even need to sign up for you
can just download the PDF or just view
them on your computer or phone screen so
thank you once again for joining me for
today's discussion all about
supplementation and more importantly how
to develop a rational and especially
effective supplementation protocol for
you and last but certainly not least
thank you for your interest in science
[Music]